[Music]
it's official the 30 era is finally here
on friday adele dropped her fourth
studio album her first full-length
release since 2015's 25. and seriously
it's time to grab a box of tissues light
a candle and get ready to weep because
these tracks are gonna tug at your
heartstrings absolutely since officially
announcing the album last month adele
has been pretty open about the fact that
these songs are mostly about her 2019
split from her husband simon kaneki the
two finalized their divorce in march it
feels like that on 30 you have literally
opened up your soul
in a way that
even though we have heard your pain
before
it feels like pain was almost like a
muse for you for this yeah it's
definitely channels from somewhere else
you know when i'm singing and when i'm
writing like and i was kind of aware of
that on the other albums but this one
you know a lot more i felt it because
everything was happening in real time
during her cbs primetime special adele
one night only the 33 year old grammy
winner explained to oprah winfrey that
she wrote the album for their
nine-year-old son angelo as a way to
hopefully answer some of the questions
he might have in the future about their
split
i just wanted for him to hear me
talking
mad madly deeply about who i am and how
i feel like you know and i don't know if
i'd ever be able to have that
conversation with him in real life and
on wednesday during her chat with zane
lowe for apple music she said one song
in particular my little love was written
just for her little boy i knew i had to
tell his story in a song um because
it was clear that he was feeling it even
though i thought i was doing a very good
job of being like everything's fine no
you know but i also knew i wasn't being
as present i can't tell his story
actually for him can't put yourself in
his shoes yeah but i can i can speak
about where he was finding himself in it
and and it was really really beautiful
[Music]
of course adele previewed some of the
new tracks from 30 during her concert
special like love is a game
[Music]
i drink wine
you better believe
[Music]
and hold on
[Music]
during her sit down with lady o adele
explained the inspiration behind the
emotional track my friends always would
say hold on when i would feel like how
i'm you know the lyrics in the verse but
it was just exhausting trying to like
keep going with it it's a process you
know the process of
of a divorce the process of
you know being a single parent the
process of not seeing your child every
single day wasn't really a plan that i
had when i you know when i had when i
became a mum and also trying to like
move forward with intention not just
trying to get out of it for no reason my
feet are walking through all of that
concrete
and while 30 might be the heartbreak
album to end all heartbreak albums adele
now says she's in a much healthier place
dating sports agent rich paul he's just
hilarious he's also hilarious oh he's so
funny okay no he's hilarious yeah and
very smart
you know he's very very smart but adele
also told oprah that her top priority is
loving herself
i don't have to expect someone else to
give me stability i can also be stable
for myself
be a solid house that doesn't blow over
in a storm
[Music]